I was very conscious you know doing Star
Trek that the it really should be
embodied and viewed through a big screen
experience so it's something used to
wait in line you should be with a big
crowd I think it's the perfect format
for it i mean its outer space for God's
sake so to see that big give the the
grandiosity of that the scale that I
Mexican afford it is pretty cool the
scope and scale of a movie like this
gets captured a timex like it doesn't
get captured in regular screens I think
that it's more vivid it's more visceral
the imax experience is a spectacular one
and when you see that kind of the mayhem
justin orchestrates in this movie
between backs lovely character stuff
it's great to see on such a massive
format because you feel like you're in
it you need nothing you can replicate at
home it's the thing that makes you want
to get out and go to the cinema burning
ship
this is the kind of movie that I max is
ideal for I know why you here why we are
all here when we're deconstructing the
enterprise thousands of people I worked
really hard to kind of put it all
together all that texture and a tactile
nature and that's something that I think
sometimes when you watch it on TV or
smaller formats you just kind of co ship
getting destroyed but here you're not
only going to see it you're gonna feel
it from the smoke the atmosphere
interaction everything that's gonna be
there for for the audience
I think I max drives that home and you
see a movie in that huge formatted ax
we're really excited about the premiere
in san diego comic-con which is going to
be a huge imax outdoor screening which
is gonna be really pretty awesome with a
live orchestra
I like the idea of being on a ride it's
a sensory overload and I think it's an
experience that it's also great to share
with other people as well I personally
love going to imax a lot of times when
you think of imax people think oh it's
just big screen but it's not it's and
it's not just big sound it's very
textured sound that's what brings the
tone of the sensibility of the film we
didn't take anything for granted
everything down to the last little
element has been thought through and so
when you go into an IMAX theater you're
really gonna help you feel not just to
see in here but feel the movie hold on
to something